[Music]
so yeah so AGI safety what are people
doing about it well one thing I think
that you you can like look at this you
like got to do some AGI safety and like
one perspective you might get is like
AGI what what is this AGI thing like do
we really understand it and now we don't
understand it like what's going on don't
know so I think there is a bit a couple
of research agendas there like what even
are we trying to address over here so
marry for example works on the embedded
agency program so I think of this as
like or probably many of you have heard
Scott's
talk about this we recommend it and the
sequence on the alignment forum that
talks about it but in a nutshell in
normal reinforcement learn in a normal
formalization of reinforcement learning
you've got the agent and got the
environment and they're separate and the
agents have interacts with the
environment by sending it actions and
the environment interacts with the agent
by sending it observations and rewards
and it's all nice and clean and crisp
and we can do lots of cool map on it but
in reality agents are going to be
embedded in their environments there's
no clean separation between the two so
this this diagram over here is a an
example of like the problem of embedded
world models so if you've got an agent
in the world and it needs to have some
sort of model of the world in order to
act within it well since the world
contains the agent the agents model of
the world is also going to have contain
a model of the agent itself and this
gives you a rise to some tricky self
referential problems so how do you deal
with that that's like the yellow section
of this box and then there are a bunch
of other sections that sadly I do not
have the time to go into yeah
another research agenda around
understanding AJ's comprehensive AI
services so
most of the time we work under the model
that we're going to have a single
monolithic agent and this monolithic
agent is going to have like some
extremely general reasoning capabilities
it'll be able to take any tasks that we
want to do and like perform it and
comprehensive AI services says yeah that
doesn't really seem to match how humans
do engineering usually we like have a
lot of modularity we build up things
with a lot of parts each part has a
bunch of has like these narrow tasks as
each part has a narrow task that it does
really well and then the interaction of
all of these parts leads you to do the
thing that you're trying to do and so
comprehensive services is basically
saying you know this is probably what's
going to happen with general AI as well
we'll be able to do complex general
tasks but it'll be with a bunch of
services like you know a special
specification generator is that then
explain the specifications to humans and
then other services that generate
designs and other services that test the
design sire come up etc etc so this is
like a diagram from the comprehensive AI
services technical report that's talking
about how you could use AI services to
design new AI systems I can do other
tasks so you still get the recursive
improvement though it's not really
self-improvement anymore because there's
no like self to improve here it's not an
agent all right so that's like oh yes so
these are both agendas around
understanding AGI but as you might guess
most of the agendas are more around like
how do we actually get an AI system to
be safe or to do what we want and so I
think one axis on which I like to think
about these different research agendas
is like what are they trying to do so
some of them are trying to prevent
catastrophic behaviors and now nice
thing about catastrophic behavior is
most behaviors aren't catastrophic then
there are other agendas that are trying
to do good things like infer human
values and then like make sure that we
take actions that are like going to do
very well according to our values but
most behavior
are not good like their if you take like
certainly if you take like some of the
randomly selected behavior it's probably
not going to do anything interesting but
even if you take some like randomly
selected intelligent looking behavior
there are many ways in which I could
like affect this room that would seem
intelligent looking but are probably not
what people in this room want like ways
in which I could affect this room that
people in this room like are like a very
small fraction of all possible ways that
I could affect this room and so this I
think the second thing is like a
reflection of what sometimes call the
complexity of human value but what is
what is the upshot of this it like good
outcomes if you want if you're aiming
for good outcomes you're like trying to
figure out how to get the a system to do
things that we will want then you need
to have a lot of information about
humans in order to like narrow down on
what those good outcomes are but if all
you're trying to do is avoid
catastrophic outcomes then maybe you
don't actually need a huge amount of
information about humans maybe it's
maybe you can do something that doesn't
really talk about humans at all and
you're still able to avoid the
catastrophic outcomes so let's talk
about those first so you can try to
avoid catastrophic outcomes by limiting
your AGI system so one proposal along
these lines is like containment or
boxing the AI so this would be things
like make sure it's not connected to the
internet or at a higher level you're
trying to restrict the channels the
input and output channels that the AI
has so that it only does things that you
so that you can monitor what it's doing
and understand what it's doing and make
sure that it's not doing anything like
particularly catastrophic or at least
that is the hook that is what has
happened to that parentheses it's
bothering me god
but yeah so that's a boxing yeah along
is similar that's more along the lines
of like view da system from as a black
box don't like think about it at all
what can we do in that thing now if we
actually look inside the AI box arts box
the the black box of the AI and like try
to affect how it chooses the actions I
does we get sort of this research agenda
of like limited agents or preventing bad
behavior and I think of this is like
mostly impact measures so if you try to
have your AGI or your AI system take
only actions that are low impact it
seems like most catastrophic things are
very high impact by at least our the
notion of impact that we have in our
heads and so if we can like formalize
that notion of impact and make sure that
our AI agents only take low impact
actions then we can probably avoid
catastrophes despite the fact that we
haven't learned anything about human
values along the way and so in the last
year there's been a bunch of work on
this there is because relative reach
ability and then Alex Turner has done
some work on attainable utility
preservation I won't really talk about
that in the most recent blog post on the
attainable utility preservation there's
these example both of these methods
currently are working on grid rules but
who knows maybe maybe they will be more
practical in the future I'm sure because
thoughts on that yeah so another way
that you could try to avoid catastrophes
not necessarily get good things but just
avoid catastrophes would be to focus on
robustness
so with robustness what you're trying to
do is just say that well actually oh my
god all of these parentheses I keep
seeing them maybe I should just not look
at my slides so with verification the
idea would be
that you've got your AI system it's
choosing behavior in some manner we
don't really care how presumably it's
usually going to do good things because
all of us are researchers in the room
are going to try to build AI systems
that do good things but you know we want
to make sure that it's never going to do
anything catastrophic so if we could
formalize what it means to be
catastrophic we could like and we could
write that down then we could use
verification techniques to ensure that
our AI system would never do anything
catastrophic so we've seen some examples
of this in narrow AI systems so for
example adversarial examples research
has some verification in it that said
that tries to prove that for a given
image classifier and a given training
test set if you change any if there are
no adversarial examples for that test
set where your adversarial examples are
talking about it is using the normal
definition of adversarial examples
similarly there was work I forget how
long ago on like verifying that a
machine learning system that was used to
control aircraft would never get the the
AI system would never let the airplane
get too close to another to into an
obstacle under like some assumptions
about what the environment looked like
and so that we could hope that these
sort of techniques will scale to the
point that we can use them on a GI
systems and but like I think the main
challenge there is like finding a good
formalization for what catastrophe is
that is sufficiently general that we can
actually get confidence out of that
other things that we have there's red
teaming which is and maybe I'll skip
over a tuning in adversarial so Red Team
red teaming is basically the idea that
we can try to train a second AI system
that looks at our a system and tries to
find inputs on which it's catastrophic
so this is like AI powered testing is
how I like to think about it and then
adversarial ml these would be things
like data poisoning or fault tolerance
you're trying to make sure that your AI
system gives good behavior even if some
like even
you're in the presence of an adversary
that is all-powerful in some particular
respect and you can think of that as
like a stand-in for like powerful
optimization that could find the catice
inputs on which your ml system is
catastrophic yeah
so that's robustness the reason I don't
have more slides about robustness is
because there is not very much research
on it that comes at it from an AGI
perspective to my knowledge so you know
it would be nice if people in this room
did more of that in the future yeah
so these are like things about
catastrophic outcomes trying to prevent
those we can also try to get AI systems
that are helpful to like actually get to
the good outcomes how might we do that
so one thing that we could try to do is
like actually infer the values that can
be safely loaded into a super
intelligent AI so this is like yep you
write bellies put them into a super
intelligent AI it optimizes them and we
are actually happy with the outcome now
this is this if this sounds really hard
it actually is really hard
so like one major challenge is how you
deal with human biases or the fact that
humans are not perfectly optimal so
let's take an example let's suppose that
I was given the choice between apples
and oranges and I chose to eat an apple
if you assume that I was perfectly
optimal then you're like yep token likes
apples very easy if you but if you can't
make such an assumption and you make no
assumption about how good I am at
satisfying my preferences then you can't
infer anything because you could say
well Rohan was actually just really
really bad at satisfying his preferences
he always chooses the thing that gets
him the least amount of utility and
therefore since he chose the Apple he
must prefer oranges and you have to make
some assumptions in order to get
anywhere and so there is a Stewart
Armstrong is basically trying is pushing
on the program that's trying to do this
by making some assumptions
you could try to analyze my brain in
order and see what the algorithm in my
brain is doing and then like by making
assumptions on what the structure of the
algorithm means you could try to infer
values that way so maybe if you see that
oh there's this part Rowan's brain that
like looks at different sorts of
outcomes like apples and oranges and
like rates them and then usually it just
picks the one that's highest and that
probably means that Rohan likes that
that system that's ranking all the
things is like what Rosen wants another
thing you might be able to do is is to
make assumptions about how particular
kinds of observations relate to values
it's like maybe if you notice a
particular facial expression of regret
and you're like okay whatever was just
happening that must have been a negative
outcome and the human are Rohan must
have dis preferred that outcome and you
could add in more assumptions of the
swarm I don't think I really fully
understand this program of research so
caveat Stewart Armstrong will probably
make this case differently but that's
how I'm making the case anyway okay
so ambitious value learning is sort of
like saying all right we've got to get
it right from the first we're going to
get values completely right right from
the beginning the instead of that you
could think of it as okay we're going to
learn preferences or valleys but we're
not going we're going to use them for
like sort of these limited tasks and
then over time we're going to use
basically this sort of human data as a
control on the AI so we don't infer
values once and for all but we instead
continually keep inferring new
preferences new values as humans learn
more be like update the values and then
what you want to do in this research
then is to get a lot of sources of data
about what human preferences and valleys
are so probably the most the one like
this is a huge research field but
probably to people in this
the most salient example will be this
backflipping hopper robot so this is
from deep reinforcement learning from
human preferences and the way this works
is you have your hopper robot do some
sort of behavior you take two videos of
the robot and you show them to a human
you ask the human to compare between the
two and say which one is more like a
backflip right and the human then says
you know the right one is more like a
backflip and you use this in order to
train a door-ward model that predicts
whether things look like a back flip and
in parallel but that you also train the
robot to actually perform the back flip
yeah and so this is a way that you can
like have humans you can use human data
in order to get an interesting behavior
in addition to comparisons between
behavior you can also have
demonstrations you can have ratings so
like putting numbers on particular
behaviors you could have a stated you
could infer preferences from a stated
reward function so that's a paper called
inverse reward design you could infer
preferences from an initial state as
well so that's a paper it just recently
completed there's a poster outside so
you can come talk to me about that at
the poster session or any other time
yeah cool so recently there's also been
a new agenda called recursive reward
modeling from deep mind and the key
problem that they're trying to address
here is that you take all of the sources
of data on the previous slide the there
is still like a lot of tasks where those
sources of data aren't enough where it's
too hard both to demonstrate the task
and also to evaluate the task so one
example would be like writing a fantasy
novel writing a fantasy novel is like
very hard to evaluate it just doesn't
you'd have to take the book that the
human that the AI wrote read through the
entire thing provide a number and then
do this many many times so that the eye
is actually able to do this
learn to write fantasy novels and that's
not going to work so the key idea behind
the cursive reward modeling is that the
evaluation is itself a task and you can
learn you can you can create another
agent that is able to perform that task
so for the fantasy novel example you
could have an agent that helps you or
you could have in the AI system that
helps you that summarizes the plotline
for you so that you can read just the
summary of the plot instead of the
entire book in order to evaluate the
plot you could have another system that
is trained to evaluate how good the
prose is etc and so you get this
basically recursive structure where
you've got your word modeling at the top
which is used to train the AI system
that's going to write a fantasy novel
and then for the evaluation the user is
assisted by another AI system which is
also trained using reward modeling cool
so all of these preference learning
methods and value learning methods so
far have been treating the human
treating have been like learning valleys
or or have been learning rewards from
data that comes exogenously it's sort of
like the human created some data the
data magically came into the AI system
from outside of the AI system and then
the AI trains on that I've learned said
but in reality just like in the embedded
agency just like in the embedded agency
the human then the AI are actually in
the same environment together the AI is
going to know about the game and observe
the human see things like that and so in
that setting how do you actually account
for that I think that's what cooperative
inverse reinforcement learning is doing
or Cyril and their what you want to do
is make a shift from optimizing from
building AI systems that optimize for
their own goals to AI systems that
optimize for our goals as on the humans
goals and you heard about this from
Stuart yesterday so I'm not going to
spend very much time on it
once you have once you start optimizing
for the humans goals and represent that
as the human skills and said they're
robots goals you start having
uncertainty over what the humans reward
function might be and this leads to
avoiding survival incentives and things
like that and like disabling off
switches and such okay so we often think
or there's this notion of corage ability
which is sometimes there are multiple
notions of cards ability in this
community
the notion I'm going to talk about is a
very broad notion so normally we sort of
think of beneficial AI systems as being
decomposed into first like what are the
values preferences ethics that we want
to instill into in the AI system which
you can think of as a definition of what
we want and then how do we actually use
that those preferences values ethics in
order to get the behavior that we want
you and that might be something like
deep reinforcement learning with chords
ability I think that decomposition is a
little bit different these instead think
of the AI system is something that is
supposed to help you and then there are
two separate aspects first is is the AI
trying to help you does it like try to
learn about your preferences if you say
oh I didn't like that does it like stop
doing the thing that it does instead
start trying to figure out what you did
want etcetera etc and then there's
companies which is is it actually good
at helping you I'm gonna ignore that
part for now and so portability is
really about this first one is like ease
the AI actually trying to help you and
or yeah is the AI actually trying to
help you so the nice thing about corage
ability is it like seems to be a concept
that we can apply to humans too I
totally can imagine like a human that is
trying to help me whereas it's a little
harder to imagine the human who was like
figured out what my values and
preferences are and that's then going to
act to optimize those values for me and
so we might hope that we can actually
train an AI system to be corrigible just
by
imitating the way that humans reason so
in this setting you might like have a
you might train a few expert humans to
reason corrigible
and then they provide training data for
any AI system which is trained to semi
simulate imitate that those humans and
so it learns chords ability by imitating
the humans now the problem with
imitation learning is that it only gets
you to human performance and ideally
we'd like to get to superhuman
performance so how might we do that well
for a superhuman one way that you can
take humans and get like really good
performances just give the humans a long
time to think it's like if I had sorry
if I had a thousand years to think about
how to play a game of chess I would
probably be able to beat probably anyone
I'm guessing maybe if I had 10,000 years
let's say there is some amount of time
where I could do it right and so if
we're if trying to imitate human
reasoning maybe there's a way to do it
such that we can simply we can scale up
to a higher performance by being able to
by being by doing enough of the
reasoning and so now you can't just have
a human thing for a thousand years
produce a single training data point and
use that to train an AI but what you can
do instead is build deliberation trees
so with deliberation trees you can think
of this is like at the top level you've
got the task that you're interested in
and then you've got a human and the
human spends maybe one hour and thinks
about how to best decompose that
question into a bunch of subtasks which
you can outsource to somebody else and
then once you get the answers from
everybody else you can make an a you can
get the answer to your original question
or task and then those sub questions
themselves are delegated to humans who
spend an hour thinking about how best to
solve those sub questions and they too
can delegate and you get this sort of
tree of deliberation of where each one
is talking about is the sub question sub
considerations needed for the level
above it and
bottom level you have questions are
small enough that a human can just
answer them in one hour and with the the
factory cognition hypothesis is that
with a sufficiently large tree you can
get to arbitrary performance on
arbitrary tasks with a you know
something like a human thinking for one
hour being each one of those nodes and
so then if we could have a an AI system
that imitates that tree then we would
get super human performance and
hopefully also corrigible reasoning and
so this is what iterated amplification
is trying to do we start with this we
start with the an AI agent that is
trained to imitate a human for who has
been thinking for like maybe an hour and
then we put that agent in and we amplify
that agent we give that agent to a human
and we say hey human here's an agent you
can ask some questions of that agent you
can use it like a bunch of times can you
now make better decisions and hopefully
the answer is yes like you can do some
sort of decomposition and then the agent
is able to answer those sub questions
for you and you make better decisions as
a result and this is used to create a
bunch of training data which you can
then imitate
which you can then imitate in order to
get a new blue agent that is that is
more capable and so that's the process
of distillation and then you can iterate
this repeatedly you've amplify again and
then distill that down to get the orange
agent in order to get agents that are
more and more corrigible more and more
capable over time while remaining
corrigible the entire time yeah so
that's iterated amplification there's
another very closely related approach
called debate debate is also working on
these sorts of deliberation trees though
here the deliberation tree is more like
arguments and counter-arguments rather
than questions and sub questions maybe I
won't go too much into it
but the basic idea is
to have to to AI systems that are
competing with each other to convince
the human of the correct answer to the
original question and so you expect them
to play through the path in the
deliberation tree that is most sort of
complicate or that is best for their own
respective positions and this allows you
to have systems that are like
considering the entire deliberation the
exponential exponentially sized
deliberation tree but the human only has
to look at like one path through the
deliberation tree and so the human can
still provide meaningful feedback right
so that's Cora bility yeah the what the
last approach I want to talk about is
interpret ability so with
interpretability this is less about
controlling the behavior of an AGI
system and more the idea that if we
could understand what our AGI systems
were doing we would be able to provide
better feedback for them so it's not
really a solution in and of itself but
it like makes basically everything else
a lot easier to do
currently there are a lot of
interpretability approaches for narrow
AI systems image classifiers are
particularly common one so this is from
I think this one is from building blocks
of interpretability which is a distilled
paper and I think the idea is that we
can observe what each each of these
pictures over here is like a name for a
neuron it's the image that would like
most activate that particular neuron in
the image classifier and then the links
between them are showing okay this
neuron influenced this next neuron which
influenced the output class the actual
decision that the classifier made and so
by looking at things like this you can
understand how your image classifier is
actually working whether it's making the
decision the decisions it is for the
right reasons
like maybe you notice that oh when it's
lifting barbells it actually note
dumbbells it actually like sees that
there are dumbbells but also has the
image of a person around it because
dumbbells are usually being held by
people and then you're like oh wait
that's wrong we need to change our
training data somehow to account for
that so yeah that's interpret ability
and that's basically all I have so the
main takeaways there five well five
avenues of research that I've
highlighted here they're also several
that I did not highlight because this is
only a 30 minute talk we can try to
build helpful AGI either by learning
preferences and getting corage ability
as a result or by learning chords
ability and getting preference learning
as a result and we can either try just
to prevent catastrophic outcomes or we
can try to make the outcomes actively
good and in the former case we hopefully
don't need as much information about
humans and that's all thanks I think
your hand for this beat overview if you
have any questions yeah thank you for
your excellent talk I have a question
about limited AGI what if people
thinking about limiting resources in
terms of compute is it naive a solution
because an AGI will find a way to break
through and find resources from nature
computational resources from nature from
collaborators or do you think that we
know some of the approaches courage
ability or even stop this for instance
the factorial Commission go into this
direction about packaging Commission so
that it's limited in terms of you give a
budget to AGI and when the budget is
over then this is done all credibility
or ability on the limited AGI front so I
am NOT I personally there seem to be a
lot of people who are interested in the
containment and like restricting
resources type of approach to
keeping AGI safe I'm personally not I I
don't find this all that compelling so
I'm like not the best person to ask
because like they probably have good
reasons that I don't know but in my case
the reason I'm like not as optimistic
about those approaches in particular is
that like I sort of see the primary
problem as economic incentives for
building AI are very strong like if
economic incentives we're building and
were not really strong we could like
take our time make sure that thing was
safe and then only then deploy it but
the reason we can do this because of the
economic incentives and so things like
limiting resources or boxing or
containment it seems to me like those
are like basically trying to stop
economic incentives which were in some
sense the reason we had a problem in the
first place that was one question the
next question was about corage ability
and mild optimization and things like
that like using those to make sure that
a GIS like try to do some tasks and then
stop did I paraphrase that right got it
I see so I think that's still that's
very different in that there you're
trying to like to change the AI system
so that it only wants to use limited
limited amounts of resources I think if
you did this in a way set where you
could control the actually I take it
back I think I like have the same answer
to that one
maybe if we like had a very compelling
case for this is the amount of compute
resources at which things are going to
be really bad and that like level is
like really high such that it doesn't
you can still do many economically
valuable things with AI if you could do
something like that then then maybe I'd
be optimistic about these approaches I
don't currently know how you would do
something like that all right I have one
more question
and the panel and any of the approaches
that you didn't cover that you can just
like fire off for us oh man so many I'm
gonna miss them now let's see concrete
problems in the eye safety I like to
think of this as like trying to scale
safety up with capabilities but that's
like sort of a broad set of things not
just one particular thing safe interrupt
ability into like there have been
proposals for like using biology as a
testbed for learning values things like
AI safety grid rolls have a bunch of
problems and them that I didn't really
talk about what else
I'm sure I'm still missing some let's
think Rohan again
[Applause]
[Music]